hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i'm
not using my main camera right now my
main camera is away from me for this
entire week while it's being sent in to
upgrade so i'm going to get that back
next week and a whole bunch of videos
are due for when i get the camera back
but i wasn't gonna let that stop me from
making a video so this is a quick ask me
video i asked a bunch of questions as i
usually do on twitter we got some good
ones we'll answer it not the main camera
but still crispy anyway a friend and i
are thinking about starting a tech
channel what are your recommendations
for us
do it no but seriously the best way to
get into something especially if you're
just getting started is to just dive in
head first a lot of people worry too
much about like the equipment or the
production quality that you want to
achieve with the very first videos you
make but honestly the first videos of
pretty much any channel if you look
backwards including mine are like
terrible so don't worry about the
equipment you have to start with just
use the smartphone or whatever you have
and just do it are you on snapchat and
if you are what's your username yes i am
and the username is mkbhd so creative
have you ever strived to make something
better on your channel because of
someone trolling you about something in
your work maybe not trolling but i
definitely pay attention to the
constructive criticism that i get which
is a benefit of having people who
actually watch the videos i make a lot
of people have this like mentality of
like i'll just ignore the haters they're
just hating for no reason but a lot of
times there's a little nugget of truth
in what you might think is just hate and
that actually can be the best criticism
or feedback you can get to make stuff
better so again maybe not trolling
making the stuff better but a lot of
your comments affect the next video i
make what are you most excited to see at
apple's event so i will be there i'm
actually flying out to the event the day
after i upload this video and a lot of
the stuff we're expecting to see at the
event is like it's already been leaked
so a new apple tv we may see a new ipad
pro with a larger display and of course
we're definitely expecting to see the
announcement of the new smartphones so
the iphone 6s and the iphone 6s plus if
that's what they keep naming it and i'm
excited to see the new cameras in these
of course the design of the s series
always tends to be the same as the
previous so upgraded internals exciting
but i really want to see how good the
new cameras are what are your feelings
on the new google logo you know what i
actually like it i think it's pretty
clean pretty simple obviously to the
casual viewer it just looks like the
same exact text in a different font and
that's fine uh what's funny is actually
verizon redid their logo like a couple
of days later i'm sure they were
developing it and spending millions on
it at the same time but it's also a
pretty simple clean redesign with the
smaller check mark and i think it's fine
i like them that doesn't mean verizon
that does not mean that i want to see it
on any home buttons anytime soon i'm
just saying i appreciate a crisp clean
logo explain the sport you play alright
so ultimate frisbee is a team sport it's
sort of a combination of like soccer
basketball maybe football and a bunch of
other stuff so there are seven on the
field for each team at a time you can
throw off like football sort of like a
football kickoff and then as you play
you pass it down the field to each other
until you score in the end zone you can
run around freely during the point but
once you catch the disc then you have to
stop you're not allowed to run with it
that's a travel like basketball but you
can move and pivot until you throw and
then you can start running again you
have 10 seconds with the disc before you
have to get rid of it or else it's a
turnover at a high level these turnovers
are a big deal which is why you'll see
players go up and over and around and
fly everywhere to avoid turning it over
which makes it an awesome sport to watch
to play and something that could be
pretty dope in the olympics why does the
oneplus 2 not have nfc alright so the
official reason given by oneplus is that
people didn't use nfc in the oneplus one
so they just didn't include it i
mentioned in my full review video of the
oneplus 2 that i think that could have
been included anyway maybe it would have
cost 10 extra dollars on the bill of
materials to eventually have that in the
final price but i think oneplus as much
as they don't like to admit it is very
focused on cost cutting and they wanted
to get that magical sub 400 price so
they decided not to include nfc and it's
also not able to be retrofitted later so
that's why it doesn't have it what's
your most favorite game of all time i
almost said nba 2k but it's actually
need for speed most wanted that game on
pc i made one or two gaming videos like
ever on my channel and one of them was
just me playing that game uh it was like
in the middle of high school that was
one of the most fun games i've ever
played i think it's the best need for
speed game ever made and it was a lot of
fun need for speed most wanted why
haven't you become a member of vessel
and will you in the future so vessel for
those who don't know is a platform for
content creators mostly youtubers to
host their content exclusively for a
while before they put it on youtube and
they have it behind a paywall on vessel
so they can be rewarded for that
i don't really have a reason to do that
with my videos i think most of them
actually benefit from going directly to
everyone for free and i also benefit a
lot from you guys commenting on the
videos immediately so it wouldn't really
make sense for me i don't think i'm
going to do that anytime soon what would
a smartphone look like if it were
designed for a t-rex so probably like
fit around their chest and would have
like a support where it would be like
two buttons on either side for their
claws probably and like i don't know it
would probably be a pressure sensitive
screen the nokia 3310 recently had its
anniversary what past piece of tech
gives you the most nostalgic feeling i
have two answers for this number one the
original motorola droid that was a phone
that i waited a long time to get when it
first came out the commercials for it
since i was on verizon were really
tempting and when i finally got it i was
pumped and i made several videos about
it and the other thing number two uh fun
fact the the first piece of tech that i
ever really got that i bought with my
own money was the first generation ipod
touch and this was before i had a
youtube channel i wanted to unbox it i
was going to go through and set it up
and customize in all sorts of ways
jailbreak it uh and then the next day at
school it got stolen
so
that never
happened that i didn't yeah not that's
not really a fun fact why hasn't apple
implemented touch screens in all their
macs honestly it's mostly because mac os
10 is not finger friendly it's not touch
screen built that's why ipads all run
ios and not mac os 10. and honestly if
you think about it if you think of like
an imac right now if it was touch screen
enabled you just have this big glossy
fingerprint covered wobbly screen on a
hinge i just feel like that wouldn't be
comfortable to type on or use anyway so
i don't expect that anytime soon what
are your thoughts on the xperia z5
premium alright so just to get it out
the way i know that it's been a while
since i've made a video about a sony
smartphone but this is going to be the
one to change that for sure the sony
xperia z5 has three variants the compact
the regular z5 and the z5 premium and
the premium if you haven't heard
has a bunch of new things about it new
materials a new back a new camera but it
also has a 4k display i called it i said
later like in this year we would see a
4k display on a smartphone and we're
seeing it already
uh yeah i want to see it and i can't
wait to get my hands on it i want to
review it i want to compare it to other
quad hd displays and all sorts of other
stuff so
yeah uh sony if you're listening to this
when is your setup tour 2015. alright so
there's always a lot of questions about
when's the next setup tour happening uh
i usually say that the next setup tour
will happen when there's a new setup so
this setup is the same as it was in the
last setup tour but when i do move or
when i change places like i've said i
would previously uh that is when i'm
going to be making a new set of tour
videos so that's that are you worried
about okc taking out your clippers next
season you know what i'm honestly not
and the thing is i realize that oklahoma
city is going to have a healthy russell
westbrook and a healthy kevin durant for
this upcoming season and that's one of
the hardest hitting one-two punches in
basketball
but the reason why the clippers were
basically doomed to failure at some
point last season is because they
weren't deep they had a great starting
five but then their bench tapered off
really quickly and i see the same
problem for oklahoma city their starting
five is going to be great but the
clippers have a massive bench now this
year they built up in an a-plus
off-season i would say i think this is
the year if any for the clippers to at
least go to the finals what drove you to
get into the whole youtube thing well
for me i've always been into tech
basically as long as i can remember and
the other thing is i have this memory of
like running around the house with a
camcorder this is a long time ago with
like a camcorder taking random videos of
things and then watching back the videos
that i made and just being like damn
that's cool that i could like see what i
just made even though it was a tape
recorder and i couldn't edit it or
anything but i've always been into video
for that reason too so video
tech
tech video
youtube tech channel just kind of worked
out do you miss having a face
you know what i didn't think we were
gonna talk about this man